- We've actually made
titty tassels before.
- (laughs) Pretty cool
(upbeat music)
(hinges creak)
- I'm getting married in a couple weeks,
and I'm super excited.
For many reasons, not least
of which is to be done
with wedding planning.
Wedding planning is not
for the faint of heart.
There are so many details,
your emotions are all wrapped up in it,
and everything is so goddamned expensive.
I started to think maybe I
should just DIY it a lot more,
and so I searched on Pinterest
for the easiest wedding
decorations you could make.
I found a bunch, and then I realized
I do not have the emotional
bandwidth at this time
to even begin to start a DIY project.
So, I'm making my coworkers
and friends try it.
I got a married couple,
I got an engaged couple.
Let's see what they can do.
- We are planning a wedding,
and it is horrifying.
- We got married last year.
We had our one-year
anniversary this Summer.
- Yeah, we did.
- It's a lot.
- Yeah, there is so much to do.
There are so many tiny details.
- We have both South
Asian and African Family.
It was three days, as well.
- I have a ton of DIY stuff pinned.
- Yeah.
- But, I also know myself,
and I know I'm not that
good at making things.
- But there were these
just huge 3-D flowers
that I wanted to make.
(man laughs)
I even did a practice
round of making them,
but it totally was a disaster.
- I think I'll be better than Sarah.
- He's probably right. (laughs)
(rock music)
- It looks like it's tassels that
hang like this from a string.
- Two at once, or one first and then
figure it out.
- Ooh, yeah yeah yeah,
let's do some layers!
- No, I didn't mean two, I
mean two at once, like you --
- Nah, nah, let's do layers!
- Fold a piece of tissue paper in half,
and then half the other way.
Cut strips toward the
fold to create fringe,
leaving about one inch
uncut at the fold line.
- You know.
- We're already going
off the script.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Partway through my first
piece of tissue paper,
and I'm already over it.
- Like, these are for a wedding,
can you please take this seriously?
- Mine are way thicker than yours.
Like, mine are thick.
- That's good cuts?
- They're better than mine.
- What's does fringe mean? I
don't know what that means.
- Funny like,
blunt-rolling technique,
(laughs)
like with tassels at the end of it.
- No, but, what's the next step?
- I don't know, I feel
like you just tie it.
- They make a loop?
- That'll have to do I think.
(snickers)
- Ooh!
- Tassels!
- I think it would take
at least 8 hours to make
a wedding's worth
- There's no way.
- of these tassels.
- But it doesn't look very good.
- They don't look good at all.
- We're not gonna make tassels.
(scoffs)
(old timey music)
- We're about to do like
DIY flower centerpieces
out of paper.
And I'm actually interested in this.
- I knew flowers would be expensive,
but I didn't realize how expensive!
- Yeap. Yeah.
- I've heard of people
making fabric flowers.
I'm considering it.
- I think we wanna make the petal.
A bunch of petals and
then we tie them together.
Alright, so let's just make some petals.
- It's starting to look like a flower.
- Yeah, brag about it.
- How do you change directions?
- Just like... you know, just like, flow!
- Just to show you what Sarah just did.
She used the instructions
portion of the tape--
- I'm so stressed out, like...
(sighs)
- They were like this,
and then the next picture's
like a beautiful flower.
I don't know how...
(laughs)
I don't know how it got there.
- Go for it, go for it.
- I'm, like, gonna go
on Pinterest and unpin
everything I ever pinned.
- Wow!
- I think these look beautiful
(laughs)
- Hope you're getting Sarah
muttering under her breath
while she makes flowers.
- We are not done!
- I refuse to make another one.
- No! (laughs)
- I'll help you, though.
- Whoa. (laughs)
- Yours is so bad!
- That's way too much work!
Real flowers, it's a plant based material.
(tropical music)
- We are now going to
make marbled votives.
- This is the votive.
- You put a candle in it.
- You just like, drop, drop, drop.
Roll, roll, roll.
Done!
- Put a few drops of
nail polish in the water.
(yelps)
- All coming off on the toothpick!
- You're probably going too fast.
(laughs)
- Oh... I ruined it.
- Please gently dip below the surface.
- Ooh... roll.
(laughs)
- Ooh!
- Okay, roll... Ay!
Boom!
- Really sick, actually!
(laughs mockingly)
- Oh, boy...
- Oh, man, you spent so
much more time on it.
And yours looks equally as shitty.
(claps)
- Looks like rainbow throw-up.
- I'd say the lesson
learned on this one is
don't do it.
(classical music)
- Some of this DIY stuff is like...
I get that you need to have
decorations at your wedding,
but like, you know... you
can chill out a little bit.
- It's like communal joy
and also communal suffering
through DIY projects.
(laughs)
- Even when it's not DIY.
- Do you have any faith in me
to DIY anything at our wedding?
- Uh, maybe like an outfit for our dog.
(laughs)
- But if you're into it, definitely do it,
because it'll make your wedding
really unique and personalized.
- None of this matters, because...
It's just a wedding.
- What?!?
(laughs)
I'm just kidding.
Like, what is a baby but, like,
the world's most important DIY project?
- That's a stretch.
(classical music)
(hinges creak)